-Mon invité a longtemps
préféré l'ombre à la lumière,
mais cela ne l'a pas empêché
de devenir porte-parole
du groupe Rassemblement National
à l'Assemblée.
Générique
...
Bonjour, Thomas Ménagé.
-Bonjour.
-Au débat sur la réforme
des retraites,
une de vos prises de parole a
déclenché beaucoup
de réactions
sur les réseaux sociaux,
mais pas seulement.
C'était sur la question du report
de l'âge légal à 64 ans.
*-Laissez-nous montrer la vraie vie,
je prends l'exemple de mon père,
il a 58 ans,
il a travaillé toute sa vie
sur les toits,
il est couvreur, mon père,
à 58 ans aujourd'hui,
chaque soir a les genoux
qui doublent de volume,
chaque matin
est incapable de se lever
parce qu'il est cassé.
Vous êtes pour la plupart
détachés des réalités,
des difficultés de ce monde,
venez sur le terrain
et vous comprendrez que,
pour une partie des Français,
il est impossible d'aller
jusqu'à 64 ans.
-Cette prise de parole a déclenché
une riposte assez cinglante
de la majorité
par la voix de Stéphanie Rist :
personne n'a
le monopole du papa qui a souffert,
a-t-elle répondu.
Vous comprenez
que ça puisse agacer,
cette façon de faire
de la politique en jouant
sur les émotions
pour défendre ses idées ?
-En s'engageant en politique,
on est le fruit de notre histoire,
de notre passé, notre famille,
donc automatiquement,
si ça touche directement
au quotidien
ou à nos familles,
on prend les exemples
que l'on connaît bien.
Donc Stéphanie Rist avait réagi,
je voulais pas m'octroyer
un quelconque monopole,
je voulais juste
expliquer au gouvernement
que des Français ne seraient
pas en capacité,
et je le savais pour avoir mon père
régulièrement au téléphone,
me disant qu'il ne pourrait pas
aller plus longtemps sur les toits,
que c'était très difficile.
Donc c'est pas du tout un monopole,
Stéphanie Rist avait peut-être
plus de pudeur, on en a parlé après,
ça l'avait un peu...
-Après, elle a raconté
que son père tenait un bistro.
-C'est ça, donc on a parlé
de nos histoires personnelles,
mais c'est ce que
je reprochais à une partie
des députés de la majorité
sur cette réforme :
quand bien même certains étaient
dans la réalité des choses,
avec des familles
parfois confrontées
à la pénibilité,
ils ont eu tendance
à l'oublier et c'est
ce que j'ai souhaité
leur rappeler.
Et par les réactions
sur les réseaux sociaux,
j'ai réalisé
que les gens se sentaient
représentés, entendus.
-Et concernés.
-Voilà,
parce que j'ai eu incroyablement,
énormément de retours.
-Trois millions de vues
pour cette vidéo
sur votre compte TikTok.
On voit que ça a suscité
des réactions.
-Oui, car aujourd'hui,
je pense que les Français
ont le sentiment
qu'on ignore la réalité,
qu'on est en orbite, hors-sol,
avec le président
et une partie des députés.
S'ils ont l'impression
qu'on est de réels porte-parole
de la réalité du terrain,
ils nous remercient.
-Je disais que ça a pu agacer
mais on sent que, en vous exprimant,
vous remuez des choses personnelles,
sur votre histoire à vous.
Est-ce que vous faites un lien
entre votre milieu social
et votre engagement
en politique ?
-Totalement.
Mes parents n'ont pas le bac...
Ca a surtout été aussi
une réelle volonté de participer
à changer les choses,
notamment l'ascenseur social.
Je viens d'une petite
commune de 800 habitants,
mes parents n'ont pas le bac,
ils se sont saignés
pour que je puisse aller
à l'université, donc déjà,
j'ai envie de les rendre fiers
et j'essaie de jamais oublier
d'où je viens,
même si j'ai fait des études,
que j'ai eu un confort personnel,
financier et un mode de vie
différent de ma famille,
à chaque fois,
surtout en tant que néo-député,
en arrivant dans l'Assemblée,
j'ai eu une pensée pour mes ancêtres
et mes parents, bien entendu.
-Très jeune, à 15 ans,
vous avez soutenu la campagne
de Nicolas Sarkozy puis vous avez
pris votre carte à l'UMP.
Mais si on vous demande
le déclencheur de votre engagement,
vous évoquez un drame personnel,
la mort de votre maman,
quand vous avez 19 ans.
-Ouais, un moment important.
Dans un premier temps,
c'était une fuite en avant.
La politique,
on se donne totalement,
c'était l'occasion
de se sentir utile,
de trouver un sens
quand on a l'impression,
quand on est jeune comme moi,
que la perte d'une maman fait perdre
un peu du sens à la vie,
de se sentir utile,
de penser à autre chose
et ça a accéléré l'engagement,
la volonté de se mettre
au service des autres
et dans un premier temps,
je le cache pas,
d'oublier ce moment qui a été
très difficile pour moi.
-En 2012, vous avez une première
visibilité médiatique,
c'était en tant que porte-parole
de la manif pour tous,
localement, à Blois.
Pourquoi vous êtes-vous mobilisé
contre le mariage gay ?
C'était lié à des convictions
religieuses ?
-Pas du tout,
c'était là encore quelques mois,
c'était réellement
ce qui a accéléré cet engagement,
après le décès de ma mère
et moi, j'ai ressenti,
sur la question de l'adoption,
si on ressort les articles d'alors,
le mariage était pas
un problème pour moi,
c'était la filiation,
je perdais
la présence féminine,
je m'interrogeais
sur la nécessité d'avoir
une présence masculine et féminine.
Je demandais aussi un référendum,
y avait un engagement
contre François Hollande.
Aujourd'hui, 10 ans après,
je regrette pas,
je l'ai fait dans le respect,
je suis très heureux de voir
que les doutes que j'avais
sur la filiation sont levés,
donc je me suis peut-être
trompé par rapport
à mes doutes et, surtout,
comme on le demande,
et c'est ce qui a participé
à mon engagement au RN,
que, sur les sujets de société,
ce soit à la société de régler
le souci par le référendum,
de la même manière,
sur des sujets bloquants,
sur les retraites,
ça aurait dû être le cas
pour l'adoption pour tous.
-Si on refaisait aujourd'hui
ce débat parlementaire,
si la loi repassait,
vous voteriez encore contre ?
-Non.
-Vous avez évolué.
-Ouais, j'avais 19 ans,
j'avais pas du tout
la même vision,
et puis le monde a évolué.
On a réalisé qu'on pouvait
avoir des inquiétudes
sur la question et que
ces inquiétudes étaient pas fondées.
En politique,
il faut surtout être en cohérence,
on a le droit de s'interroger
et, aujourd'hui, je suis content
que tout le monde puisse
s'aimer librement en France,
je m'inquiète pour les homosexuels
sur d'autres combats,
notamment contre le fondamentalisme
islamiste qui menace des droits,
et donc cette question,
il faut pas rouvrir,
même si on est dans les 10 ans,
c'est réglé.
-Les rares images que j'ai
retrouvées de vous à l'époque,
en fouillant ici et là,
c'est les seules qu'y a.
Y a plus rien de vous
sur les réseaux sociaux,
notamment sur vos comptes.
Vous avez tout effacé ?
-Quand j'ai pris un engagement
auprès de Nicolas Dupont-Aignan,
j'ai remis en cause l'ensemble
de mes réseaux sociaux
parce que la parole d'un gamin,
les photos de famille,
les photos avec les proches,
des prises de position
quand on est gamin...
-Oui,
ça, je comprends,
mais un engagement public ?
Comme si vous n'assumiez plus ?
-J'ai recommencé des comptes
à zéro juste après,
je voulais pas être responsable
des propos que je pouvais avoir
à 15 ans sur les réseaux sociaux,
mes photos en soirée
avec mes amis, y avait rien
de répréhensible ou de gênant,
ce qu'il y avait dans la presse
était clair mais je considérais,
quand on devient un personnage
politique public,
qu'il faut être responsable
de ses propos.
Depuis mon engagement,
tout est public, bien sûr.
-En mai 2014,
vous avez posté une photo
de votre carte de militant UMP
en vous interrogeant
sur rester ou non
au sein du parti,
puis vous l'avez quitté
pour rejoindre Nicolas
Dupont-Aignan, pourquoi ?
-J'avais des doutes,
comme beaucoup de militants UMP,
même si j'étais
pas pleinement engagé,
sur la ligne du parti,
la défense des classes moyennes,
la valeur du travail.
Depuis Nicolas Sarkozy,
j'avais des doutes
sur la capacité à passer
le karcher, sur le régalien,
sur la souveraineté.
A l'époque, moi,
j'étais pas prêt à rejoindre
le Front National,
c'était encore
le passé de Jean-Marie Le Pen.
Et celui qui portait la ligne du RPR
ancien et qui était compatible
avec Marine Le Pen,
c'était Dupont-Aignan.
-Vous devenez
son chef de cabinet
en 2015,
vous êtes resté dans son ombre
le long de cet engagement,
mais au coeur du dispositif,
au point que vous avez
participé directement
aux négociations avec Marine Le Pen,
après la présidentielle,
avant la législative
de 2017.
Ca a été une étape-clef
de votre engagement,
qu'est-ce qui s'est joué
pour vous à ce moment-là ?
-C'était un moment important,
c'était le premier contact
avec Marine Le Pen,
le moment où j'ai réalisé que,
loin de fantasmes
que j'avais personnellement
véhiculés par des opposants,
par petite doxa médiatico-politique,
bah, Marine Le Pen est une femme
humaine avec qui on avait
eu des échanges très clairs,
dans l'intérêt général,
dans l'intérêt de la nation.
-Donc pourquoi pas elle ?
-Oui, et ça m'a forcé,
alors que j'étais encore jeune,
à négocier cet accord
aux côtés de Dupont-Aignan,
énormément autour de lui refusaient
de travailler avec Marine Le Pen.
Ce premier contact m'a donné envie
de m'engager pour elle.
-Vous êtes plusieurs députés RN
à avoir une place
importante à ses côtés à être
passés par Nicolas Dupont-Aignan.
On vous voit avec Alexandre Loubet
ou Jean-Philippe Tanguy, ici.
Vous avez créé ensemble
un micro-parti,
comme on dit, L'Avenir Français,
ça veut dire que c'est
une bonne école de la politique,
Nicolas Dupont-Aignan.
Vous lui devez beaucoup ?
-Oui,
c'est un excellent élu local,
j'ai appris énormément
et je suis ultra heureux d'être
avec mes compagnons de route,
qui étaient à Debout la France,
aujourd'hui aux côtés
de Marine Le Pen.
Ce qui est certain,
c'est qu'on a pas changé,
on veut le rassemblement
des patriotes,
des nationaux,
pour sauver le pays
et éviter d'être
dans l'ornière actuelle.
-Vous allez aux législatives
sous les couleurs
de L'Avenir Français,
avec le soutien
du RN et de Marine Le Pen.
Jean-Michel Blanquer
a choisi de se présenter
dans la même circonscription
que vous,
ça a eu pour conséquence
de braquer les caméras sur vous.
Vous diriez que
la candidature de Blanquer
a été une chance pour vous ?
-Oui, en quelque sorte,
ça m'a obligé à arrêter d'être
le garçon timide qui voulait être
en arrière-plan
à pas répondre aux caméras.
Ca m'a forcé, pour une question
d'équilibre du temps de parole,
je devais m'exprimer,
ça m'a permis aussi
de me faire un petit peu
un petit nom à ce moment-là
et de pouvoir,
dès mon arrivée à l'Assemblée,
être porte-parole.
-Très vite après votre élection,
Marine Le Pen vous repère
et vous nomme
porte-parole du groupe RN
à l'Assemblée,
vous voilà encore plus
en pleine lumière
alors que vous dites
ne pas aimer cela.
Pourquoi ?
Vous avez l'air plutôt à l'aise.
-J'aime pas l'image que je renvoie,
c'est de la psychologie,
on s'aime ou on s'aime pas,
on apprend à s'aimer,
on grandit, physiquement,
dans la manière de s'exprimer,
et dans un premier temps,
j'avais un complexe de classe,
un sentiment d'imposteur,
en arrivant ici, et historiquement,
c'est-à-dire que je me disais :
qu'est-ce que le petit gars
de la ruralité,
dont les parents
ont pas fait d'études,
fait dans ce milieu ?
-Vous vous sentiez pas
légitime à votre place ?
-J'ai la légitimité
des urnes,
mais je me sentais
pas à ma place et je pense que
ça arrive à énormément de députés
qui ne viennent pas
des milieux habituels,
qui ne répètent pas
la vie familiale,
qui sont d'une famille
très politisée,
on a l'impression
que c'est pas pour nous,
c'est pour ça qu'il faut des jeunes
issus d'autres milieux en politique,
c'est pas réservé aux fils-de,
fils à papa,
l'Assemblée doit représenter
tous les Français.
-On passe à notre quiz.
Je vous explique
comment ça se passe :
je vais commencer une phrase
et vous allez devoir la compléter.
Ce qui m'agace le plus
à l'Assemblée ?
-Le brouhaha permanent,
le fait que chacun est là
pour faire sa vidéo, son buzz,
et pas forcément toujours
pour débattre du fond.
Et la deuxième chose qui m'agace,
c'est le côté
très sectaire des autres groupes.
Je vote des propositions
de tout bord, je pense juste
à l'intérêt des Français,
ce que tous ne font pas.
-Contrairement au RN,
l'avenir français ?
-Le RN, mouvement de rassemblement,
ni droite, ni gauche,
gauche et droite, nous,
nous sommes de droite gaulliste.
-Vous assumez ?
-De droite gaulliste sans hésitation
et la beauté du RN
est de rassembler des personnes
qui viennent d'horizons différents.
-Dans une autre vie,
je rêverais de ?
-D'avoir du temps
parce que c'est la problématique
en politique maintenant,
on se rend compte à quel point
c'est une denrée rare,
d'avoir du temps pour sa famille,
ses proches, pour souffler et,
des fois, prendre une bouffée
d'air frais et être
encore plus efficace
pour défendre les Français.
-Merci beaucoup,
Thomas Ménagé,
d'être venu.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
...